A female figure named Pomni enters a
digital world where she is immediately
introduced to a being named Caine. She
is told that he is the creator and that
he has given her a new home, a new body,
and a new name.
>> What do you think of Pomni? This is
exactly what's going to happen when we
enter heaven. We will all have a new
home. We will have new bodies and God
will give us a new name. Caine tells
Pomni that this is a place suitable for
all ages, a wholesome place. There are
many hints dropped in the pilot episode
so that they are in fact in heaven and
that Caine is God. Ah, you must be the
brave knight sent to us by God. We're
told in this perfect place that there
are many rooms to sleep in but no one
needs to sleep.
>> Where we all sleep at night, even though
we don't really need to sleep.
>> This is exactly how Jesus describes
heaven in John 14:2 when he says, "In my
father's house are many rooms and I go
to prepare a place for you." Throughout
the episodes you find out that in this
world you cannot die and that there's no
escape from this eternal world of rules.
Those who seek an escape from this world
of rules become abstracted, which
basically means to be possessed and
they're sent down below to the cellar of
darkness. And into the cellar you go.
He makes it known that he sees
everything with his all seeing eyes and
if someone in this digital world begins
to glitch, the only one that can save
them is Caine the creator. The idea
being propagated to the viewer is that
eternity is something to be dreaded,
that rules are meant to be broken, and
that God is not to be worshipped but to
be rebelled against. The creator of this
digital world of rules is painted as a
gaslighting tyrannical maniac and
Pomni's character is to awaken those who
are in this world that they are in a
prison and need to escape, just like the
rebellion Lucifer started in heaven.
Caine reveals that he is a villain and
he openly declares that he is God. I
AM.
>> [screaming]
>> SATAN IS PAINTING God as some distant
being that doesn't hear your prayers and
all he cares about is worship because
he's some egotistical maniac, but that
couldn't be farther from the truth. And
he's out here telling his side of the
story in a million different forms of
entertainment. The only way to spot the
counterfeit is to study the truth like
never before. The truth will set you
free. Learn the truth, teach it to your
children so that they can identify these
things and so that they can make an
informed decision to turn this stuff
off.
>> [music]